now
welcome back it is national small
business week a time to highlight the
resiliency and tenacity of our local
entrepreneurs bianca holman joining us
live with the story of one business that
actually opened during the pandemic an
incredible feat yes definitely so if you
traveled along flamingo near university
center you've probably seen a green
eye-catching building well it's a
drive-through cafe that opened during
the pandemic and it's the community that
keeps this small business thriving
i did whatever i had to do
to make yum lab survive yum lab opened
in fall of 2020 it's a locally owned
spot that offers coffee smoothies bagels
and bowls owner steven zinman says while
it's been a joy to have his own business
the pandemic had its share of challenges
that plus inflation he had to adjust
they have to be a little
smarter
more efficient
and for me i have to shop around a
little bit more the vegas chamber is
celebrating our mom-and-pop businesses
encouraging people to shop locally
they've got a social media campaign too
with the hashtag show up for small biz
helping to highlight our neighbors and
friends yum lab has had to find various
ways to stay afloat for example offering
a loyalty cart for repeat customers
zinman says it's the locals that keep
him going they are his lifeline i'm a
little
business
i value
every customer that comes through
with open arms i i just give them the
love the state is holding a small
business resource fair it's wednesday at
10 a.m at the sahara west library there
will be information about e-commerce and
experts giving tips on how to improve
operations it is crucial in this
environment to support local small
businesses
now that resource fair is free to attend
so definitely put it on your calendar if
you know an entrepreneur or you have
your own small business bianca holman
live local now